et puis si vos amis amateurs de bonne
chère et de bons vins ont de l'humour
mais beaucoup d'humour vous pourrez leur
offrir le nouveau vin qui fait son
apparition en bourgogne
fera t-il notre bonheur christian pas là
en tout cas le fait déguster aux
passants le modèle vrai bon du coup avec
- oui bien sûr si vous êtes un vrai
bourguignon et alors
ça vaut pas un petit peu marre je suis
pro régime ont enfin
[Musique]
pour que c'est bien non nous ne sommes
pas dans une pharmacie mais dans un
magasin de diététique où l'on trouve ce
vin sans alcool depuis un mois du blanc
du rose et du rouge à zéro degré mais
vendre un tel produit à dijon dans la
capitale du bourgogne
n'est ce pas un peu de la provocation je
pense que c'est même un complément car
les vins de bourgogne sont bons sons
gouleyant mène à porte parce que les
qualités d'un vin sans alcool ou
linkedin pour soi tout à fait y avait
une attente de la clientèle et déjà nous
avons vendu beaucoup de bouteilles de
vin sans alcool qui vous achète souvent
beaucoup de personnes âgées des
personnes en convalescence des sportifs
quelques diabétiques
nous sommes allés poursuivre notre
enquête à la gare de dijon à la
recherche de spécialistes du problème
plus habitué il est vrai aux 12 degrés
voici l'avis de roland et d'andré
originaire de chaumont et de mulhouse un
avis pour le moins étonnant il est beau
il est bon ouais il est bon le vin de la
vigne
il est bon
d'être bourguignon
oh
[Musique]
il est bon d'être bourguignon
quand je vois
rouge une consolation pour les
bourguignons ce vin sans alcool est
fabriqué dans l'aude et en bordelais
[Musique]